it is the season to be cautious some are
more cautious than others when it comes
to the uk's constituent part
edinburgh's hogmanay stage will lie
empty and unused next week after
cancellation of its ogmony events
coupled with restrictions in scotland on
hospitality the business of tackling
covet hasn't gone down well with
business itself
in this edinburgh restaurant hogmanay is
typically a high point in the calendar
not this year
and i mean i was closed for 14 months
open in may
it's taken us all this time to build up
again and now we're going to have to
start from scratch again next year i
mean the only way forward for me
is to start doing home deliveries so
because there's going to be no customers
coming into the restaurant
and i guess for
the vast majority of hospitality i'm
going to have to do the same
get vaccinated was the prime minister's
christmas message
and the word to last minute shoppers in
york and elsewhere in england was that
there will be no last-minute
announcement on restrictions there at
least until monday
if the pile of scrumpled wrapping paper
is bigger this year it is
precisely because across the country in
the run-up to christmas
we've been giving each other
an invisible
and invaluable present
new figures from the office for national
statistics show an estimated 1.7 million
in the uk had coronavirus last week
england had the highest rate of
infection one person and 35 scotland was
lowest with one in 65.
we can see that less people
are coming into a hospital
and it appears that there is a reduced
signal of
risk of hospitalization these are very
early days it's very small numbers and
most of the cases of omicron in this
country so far to date have been in
younger people we're only just now
starting to see them tip into the uh
over 60s and just this week into the
over 70s group and that's where we start
being very worried
the restrictions announced by scotland's
first minister lean towards the more
severe scene around the uk
i know that even three or four weeks ago
all of us were looking forward to a
fairly normal christmas i'm so sorry
that this year's won't be quite like
that
in wales large events won't be allowed
indoors or outdoors after christmas and
nightclubs will be closed the new
infection figures show that in wales one
person and 45
had coronavirus last week
in northern ireland the figure was one
in 40.
among new restrictions there numbers at
a non-domestic gathering will have to be
determined by an operator's risk
assessment
not for the first time tackling covet is
a challenge seen differently from each
of the four corners of the uk
the view varied
on political guidance personal
responsibility and where the two should
meet
experience and definitive data will be
the ultimate arbiter in time
just not in time for christmas
james matthews sky news edinburgh